okay I've got a pretty big announcement
to make actually in terms of upcoming
new programming for the David Pakman
show
so the context of this is that yes since
March 31st 2017 the David Pakman show is
getting crushed by what is known as
YouTube ad pocalypse aka YouTube D
monetization I've shown you the revenue
curve for YouTube on the program before
we have it up on the screen right now
for our TV and video audience and as you
can see at the beginning we started the
year off strong and then revenue just
absolutely fell off of a cliff
due to the YouTube D monetization crisis
now I've explained it before and I don't
want to bore the audience explaining
exactly what this is again but there
have actually been a couple of articles
written about what D monetization is and
specifically how it's affecting our show
one really good article by Amanda Hess
in the New York Times called how
YouTube's shifting algorithms hurt
independent media you can read about
what's going on there another very good
article written by Davey Alba in Wired
magazine called want a better web here's
an idea
pay for it so what we've been doing and
I'm leading up to the big announcement
what we've been doing to try to recoup
the lost revenue number one we have
membership people if you've been
listening or watching for a while you
probably know about membership you sign
up at david pakman.com slash membership
the prices are very reasonable you get
extra content but if you want to pay
less you can do so with the coupon code
I voted 17 fine people know about
membership we added patreon patreon is
similar to membership in that you make a
contribution on a monthly basis to the
show we have similar benefits the bonus
show the commercial free TV show you can
do that at patreon.com slash david
pakman show now if you're watching with
us what you see on the screen here is
that we have this goal of 2,000 patrons
right when we reach 2,000 patrons it's
kind of a silly goal but I've agreed to
do an entire broadcast show from the
studio with my hair as I'm calling it
uncontrolled and this is a pretty scary
thing for really a lot of people but
particularly children who this is
really the stuff of nightmares but
that's kind of a joke right we'll get to
2,000 patrons someday and I'll do a
broadcast show with my hair like this
here is the new thing that we're doing
based on my offer to maybe look at
putting my Boston College lectures up on
YouTube or on the internet we are going
to be creating a new patreon target okay
and if you're saying Boston College
lectures what are you talking about I am
now teaching as an adjunct professor at
Boston College and there is a lot in the
class about media literacy and critical
thinking and filter bubbles echo
chambers and new media talk media and
those lectures I've offered and said
what if we recreated those with the
slides and did these long-form lectures
on interesting subjects and put them
online people loved it people have
emailed tweeted posted to Facebook
YouTube etcetera
please do it so I want to do it but
there are some significant tech
requirements editing time it's a whole
thing
as I often like to say so what I am
proposing to you today is we have
established a new patreon target of
2,500 okay when we have 2,500 patrons we
will produce and post these lectures
first to the patreon audience but
because it's important we will after
make them available for everybody on
YouTube I think it's really important
actually that this material be available
for everybody if we're going to go
through the trouble and time for
producing it I do want to make it
available to everybody but because it'll
be triggered by our patreon patrons we
will first make these lectures available
through patreon ok so again when we get
to 2,000 patrons we'll do the hair thing
I mentioned the hair thing and we'll do
the hair thing I'll do an entire show
from the broadcast studio with my hair
out of control but when we get to 2500
patrons at patreon.com slash david
pakman show it will be time for
Professor Pakman for lack of a better
term and the great thing is this won't
be determined by how much you can pledge
I'm not saying once we raise X number of
dollars I'm saying once we get 2500
contributors we will produce the full
master of critical thinking media
literacy etc lectures from the college
course I am teaching at Boston College
so $1 contribution counts the same as
$100 contribution towards that 2500
contributor goal I think it's a great
thing
help us out let's do it patreon.com
slash david pakman show